all right Sancho won part one uh
can someone get that please
please Sancho one part one makes a lot
of use of mushido technicon
ushiro tenkon
is not eating me 10 card
so ushiro tenkon is a yumiashi to the
rear okay so I'm gonna shift my weight
onto the back foot and that's where I
rotate pull
and then clear the line of attack
it is a
it is very very practical especially in
real life when a much stronger dude is
attacking you okay uh you will not be
able to say yeah okay he's coming at me
you see I I will not be able to eat Amy
and ten con because he's pushing on me
you guys see that
so he's pushing on me I can't get that
ad major get out of the way
instead as he pushes on me I yield and
that's where the in space I create with
edema with uh Ishida tenko Shido 10kan
okay again you're you're very used to uh
a guy's coming out here and you're like
you're gonna go like this and do that
yeah I I have found it in real violence
to not be very practical in playing
around yes but in real the ashino10 Kong
works way better when you're out
Okay so
Sancho one part one is
I do not want to take two steps
ever it's one step so as he goes it's
not clear the line of attack and then
come around
it's clear the line of attack here
and attack
watch the Rhythm change
you see
so in that 2B
he's gonna attack again
in the 1B
you're already hitting him okay he if he
pulled that joke that's where I would
hit him
so
one
and then out of the way
out of the way attack
okay fine the next place you have the
ushito ten con
foreign
because that 2B is going to allow him to
ski twice or to distract me
and hadai is
uh not an attack that is hitting him
forward it's he's running into my weapon
okay so that that's important so we go
and I'll show you what I mean one
boom hop I'm going to get out of the way
of this thing here's the turn right and
I'll hit him as he's coming forward on
the hot eye
it's a stop hit just like he's uh we're
boxing he comes in at me box I hit him
as he's coming in as opposed to me going
forward with my job I'm here we'll total
man I think him as he's coming in or
he's running at me boom and I hit him as
he's coming towards me as he puts the
front kick where I close the gap okay
so ushiro Ken Khan
is there he's coming into me okay
so we'll go slow to look at you ushero
tankard
boom
here is the Michigan that foot stays
where it is okay and I hit him as he's
coming back into me
foreign
so a lot of confusion comes because
harai is not understood as a stop hit
when you don't make it a stop hit you're
gonna have a guy that's waiting there
for your strike and you just end up
changing um
blows okay so you take turns okay so
um
move on so I'll show you what I mean
here his turn my turn
his turn
my turn see that
that's not Marshall we don't take you
don't take turns okay so for example if
we go to the beginning it's as he's
bringing his Joe back for another ski
that's gonna be that's where I hit him
done do you see end of the fight okay so
that gives him as he sees the strike
coming around from his ski he's not
gonna throw another ski it stopped his
attack he's gonna defend so he doesn't
get that do you see and I'm going to
again not go one two because he's gonna
take control of my weapon I'm gonna do
Cami boom around to free my hand so he
doesn't disarm me he's going to take
advantage of the opening and try to end
it okay
so when he tries to end it there go back
as opposed to a little County coup
do it the accounting Coop do it pop do
it
that's not gonna end it okay he's gonna
put his
whole body into it where I go whoa I
can't take that
if I even if I could he would displace
me and get me with the next attack
so I had to deviate
before I'm not gonna put him close you
see you got it
and now khadai is not Trading blows had
eyes attacking him in the middle of his
attack which is Marshall okay
so
if if you're all good there
you're going to see that his only
counter is deviation just like mine was
on uh the machiatosh
my only counter is to stop the disarm
so the same thing on the hot eye
when he's when he feels he's
gonna get out of the way
that's forcing him to not attack he has
to deviate okay
so
um
if you go back and you look at the hot
eye as a stockist we got really close
he he's penetrating that allowed me to
hit him as he's coming in
is very close look how close we are
see and we would probably start
grappling that's an option you can you
can go the stick and you'll start
grappling
but he wants to go back to his weapon
and that's why he deviates and comes
around
and now he's back at Joe range now we're
not grappling anymore
so if you look at in terms of my
we're going to get close
we're going to rotate
and then we're going to go apart again
back to Joe range which is what you do
all the time in your Aikido so his his
energy is pushing I'm going to go close
and we're going to rotate and we're
going to separate right okay
so we'll trade rolls
ski attack the disarm the fans boom that
would have been the end
so instead as I see back to back one
move other side okay as I ski it I
realize I come around
I deviate around
but I want to move out of the grappling
range
so
boom
boom here
there's a win
when you do it when he goes from the hot
eye to the ski that's a Yin space
so around
boom pop rolls there is when I can move
you have a couple ways of doing it
you can do your front foot
and if I do the back foot
but the problem with the back foot is
you're still in grappling range so he's
going to kick you boom
so I like the front foot
[Music]
around
okay and then
he won't have his kick
he won't have the strike I force him to
have a boom to defend his head so he's
got a deviate
and here it is right here
okay
so we're not trading blows I'm forcing
him to counter if he does not counter
he's going to get hit by that technique
foreign
that strike now so when he comes around
oh I yield
get my hands out of the way
[Music]
now he sees the opening
he's going to withdraw because go back
this is a baby strike
do it
I'm not gonna care
so he's got to withdraw and then his
body flow comes in you see
so he hit the he killed the weapon he
withdraws and now I'm going to do
another ushito ten con not Ed me ten
Khan
ushino tenkon because he's gonna miss
and then what's he gonna do he's going
to want to draw it again
right that's when I hit him
so at the beginning he sees
ushiro tenkon
at the harai
Khan and then as we switch roles
he's gonna do another ishido tank mod
hit
so part one has a lot of ushiro tenkon
in it okay try it again
so we're throughshido tank on you're
learning how to deviate ski so you
deviate deviate do you see whoa County
pv8 okay and I came around he came
around right home
Here Comes his ski again you see he goes
I move out of the place
[Music]
you think
okay so there's a lot of angle deviation
that is in your defense it's not
deflection it's not his weapons there
and you move it out of the way you get
out of the way
and your deflection angle is redundant
with your deviation angle it's not
dominating
it's here he missed attack okay so as we
come around again boom and I move right
uh I would be trying to hit his head
when you come back
I would be trying to hit his head
stay there
look where his head is
as I'm trying to hit his head I'm not
trying to hit his joke don't move I'm
trying to go boom and end that so watch
that angle
on the ceiling or maybe over here camera
you see quack and end it
but he did not finish his take on he
finishes his tank on that head is not
there do you see that and so now I take
the next opportunity which is his weapon
and his hands and he takes the chemical
you see
so we go
deviation
back in yep
yep boom we go deviation back in now we
deviate on each other
heated one watch his feet he did one
because he wants to go out of grappling
range out of kicking range he did front
foot one next foot two next foot three
come back
I did too
he goes one
two I'm gonna get a beat on his head
before him
so I aimed there
okay so I had had I
one two that's where I ate but he's
gonna deviate with the yoshido tank on
and I own I missed his head and he
checked that from his head but I take
the next thing pull down on his hands
then this one okay what you don't want
to do
[Music]
is from Hanoi
aim at his stick
that's not that's not it he would come
around and hit I'm done okay you aim at
his head and his deviation saves him
okay his deviation is a chemical all
right